moi aussi j'ai eu des vannes qui passent
pas depuis tout à l'heure si c'est très
compliqué c'est terrible un sourire aux
césar c'est un standing ovation au parc
des princes c'est l'exercice lui-même et
la mécanique de cette cérémonie
vous avez parmi les 1000 personnes 300
personnes qui sont nommés terre au début
de la soirée tout le monde est plein
d'espoir il rigole ovale ils sont
contents meilleur décor il ya cinq mecs
qui sont en costard cravate et qui
s'engueulent savas qui dit si je peux
gagner quand le meilleur décor est
attribué à
les quatre autres qui étaient prêts à
rire qui était comme ça ils ont une
femme avec eux ils ont des copains ils
ont un agent ça fait à peu près 20
personnes 20 30 personnes qui n'ont pas
de césar qui deviennent des losers fous
ils s'éteignent
ils font sûrement sourire maintenant et
là on a un autre césar funai qu'ils
gagnent et encore 20 personnes qui donc
la salle augmente de losers elle se
peuplent de losers qui ont pas envie de
rigoler à tes vannes meta dégâts tout
seul qui rigole skizomeuh le césar mais
ça fait pas d'ambiance
moi j'ai regardé toutes les cérémonies
pour avant de présenter tu es obligé de
regarder pour voir ce qui s'est fait ce
que tu aimerais faire acquitter envie de
ressembler à qui t'as pas envie de
ressembler ce que tu respectes mec t'es
pas capable de faire humoriste du monde
leur métier c'est de ces de 2,2 de
changer une virgule de refaire la vanne
à l'envers de césar comme chaque année
vous sera remis en version compressée
on va voir un modèle tout de suite que
vous connaissez voilà mai
si beaucoup merci c'est gentil mais vous
aurez la possibilité cette année d'opter
pour la version non compressé du césar
dont vous pouvez apercevoir ici de suite
merci là aussi il faut vraiment la la la
la dose et l'écrire la mesure et la
polir pour qu elles pour qu'elles
arrivent juste quoi et à une seule
chance un seul soir j'aimerais
m'adresser aux critiques de films et
leur dire que quand il critique un film
c'est aux monteurs qui font le plus de
mal quand il démonte un film
[Musique]
non moi j'aime pas trop c'était il ya un
moment
très fort que j'ai vécue parce qu'il
était totalement improvisé c'est les
changes qui a eu avec philippe noiret
pendant la première cérémonie que j'ai
présentée non à monsieur noir et
monsieur noir et qui a rigolé tout le
temps on a fait ça et ben lui je lui
fais confiance
c'est mon baromètre merci à l'académie
de l'avoir placé au premier rang quand
tu présentes les césars des moments de
pure impôts tu t'en souviens quand ça
sort un peu des rails du temps souvient
et ce soir là avec philippe noiret j'ai
vécu un moment qui est d'ailleurs c'est
ça qui m'a donné l'année d'après l'idée
de lui proposer vraiment de faire un
sketch et il l'a accepté
philippe noiret a déclaré le cinéma
c'est mon dada
non je n'ai jamais dit une imbécillité
pareil je m'attendais on a des gens qui
travaillent dix documents qui ont
cherché à tuer je vous avais dit le
cinéma c'est mon dada d'enchères ses
magazines en 84 mon grand garçon ça
débute est pas mal
j'avais tiré 2 3 sourire vous avez votre
petit répertoire de blagues décalé
les mêmes depuis 30 ans qui viennent
maintenant que canal+ n'ont pas vous
mais enfin celle alignée mais je vous en
prie sur les gentils on passe à autre
chose maintenant je n'ai jamais dit une
connerie pareille vous avez jamais dit
ok vous n'avez jamais dit le le cinéma
c'est mon dada
je n'ai jamais dit ça il aime regarder
dans les zi philippe noiret j'ai jamais
dit le cinéma c'est mon dada et puis
revenons à l'essentiel c'est-à-dire
cette soirée que vous tentez de
présenter ouais parce que jusqu ici pour
l'ambiance c'est quand même un petit peu
juste l'impression d'être à la pendaison
de crémaillère une petite supérette dans
la banlieue de toulouse